this is like a 90s movie like an early
2000s movie that it we're being spied on
with a balloon uh and Joe Biden's like
we're gonna we're gonna take care of
this surveillance balloon believed to be
from China and first scene above Montana
is being tracked as it flies over the
continental United States is this what
try I thought China was very
sophisticated I thought China was doing
like a lot of corporate Espionage and
they had spies in this country that are
born here like my godson that will grow
up and live here like I thought China
was doing this really high level [__]
this is what they're doing they're
sending a hot air balloon
maybe we don't really have to worry
about them is it okay to be less worried
about China now that this is the type of
crap they're doing like frat pranks
they're sending hot air balloons to spy
on Montana maybe they don't really know
what's going on we tend to think China
is like the biggest threat but maybe
they're not we don't know